Hey guys!
If you've been hoping to get
the Nintendo Switch with Mario Kart 8,
today is your last chance.
Contest is closing.
There's a link down in the description.
This self filling pet water dish
is super easy to build,
and is made of very low cost materials.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
Today, we're gonna be showing you
how to build a self refilling pet water bowl,
and it's a very simple build.
It goes together quickly,
and is easy to use.
To get started, we've got
a scrap of half-inch board,
a piece of 2x4,
an empty soda bottle,
a pet food dish,
and a little patch of velcro.
The basic idea is that
our pet dish will hold water,
and will be refilled by
a reservoir in our soda bottle.
Piece of 2x4 will be
attached to the board,
and our soda bottle will be
able to attach and detach from there.
The board doesn't really have
specific size requirements
other than being big enough to hold
the food container and a board behind it.
For this design, we're also
going to use a piece of 2x4
as a support behind the pillar.
So we'll cut that,
and then measure how big
we need our board to be,
to hold all of the pieces together.
[Music]
From our scrap of 2x4,
I cut a wedge with a 90 degree angle
that should nicely support our pillar.
[Music]
This is going to be around pets,
so just to make it a little bit safer,
let's sand down all of the edges,
sharp corners, and splinters.
[Music]
With our board measured and cut,
we can now see where the bowl,
pillar, and support piece will fit.
Now, let's attach our support pillar
to our board with a few screws.
I have marked off where
our support pillar was sitting,
and we'll now drill
down through the top,
three different spots
where our screws will go.
After we have those drilled out,
we can put our board back in place,
and drill from the other side.
This will help us know that
we're drilling in just the right spot
as we drill the pilot holes into the 2x4.
[Music]
With three screws attaching
our pillar to the board,
it's pretty sturdy.
But just to be sure,
let's use a few more and
add a support piece on the back.
Don't split, don't split, don't split.
[Music]
The support pillar is now very sturdy,
and can handle just about
whatever we throw at it,
which is just what we want it to be.
We need a way to attach
the soda bottle to the support pillar,
but still be able to move it up and down,
and to remove it,
so we can refill it.
This is where our velcro
patches come into play.
These patches will hold
themselves together
with quite a bit of force.
It should be enough to hold even
a full soda bottle without falling.
The level of the water in the dish
will be determined by how high,
up or down,
our bottle is placed.
The water will fill to the level
of the bottom of the bottle.
So if we have our bottle near the bottom,
there will only be a little bit of water.
If we have it near the top of the bowl,
the whole bowl will fill.
The velcro patches
come with an adhesive side,
and we'll stick one
of those onto our soda bottle.
For the matching fuzzy side of our velcro,
we can figure out a spot
that will let us put it both
at the lowest point
and the highest point.
That height looks like a good point.
Mark that.
[Music]
It's very sticky.
After attaching both sides of the velcro,
we want to give it at least 15 minutes
for the glue to really settle
before we add any weight,
or try and put the pieces
together and pull them apart.
In the meantime,
let's see if we can secure
our bowl to the base,
a little bit more than
just letting it rest there.
With this particular design of dish,
the middle bottom portion of the bowl
isn't making contact with the board.
I've got a little scrap of thin board,
and I think we can trim
that to the right size,
and have that make up the difference
between the edge of the bowl and the center.
We can then use another piece
of velcro to attach onto that spot,
as well as the bottom of the bowl.
This way, the bowl will
stay where we want it,
until we try to peel it up.
A little bit of wood glue should hold
this piece down in place forever.
[Music]
Add a little bit of weight,
and let it sit for about 30 minutes.
[Music]
Velcro patch part one and two,
our bowl should now stay nicely in place.
[Music]
That's not coming off.
With our bowl attached,
and our velcro having
had time to cure in place,
we can now attach the bottle
onto the side of our post.
And it should stay just exactly in place.
All we need to do now
is refill this bottle with water,
and start filling our bowl.
[Music]
To start filling,
let's turn our bottle upside down,
and quickly lower it to
the level of the bottom of the bowl.
We can then raise it higher
to the level we want the water to fill.
[Music]
At this point, with the neck
of the bottle under the water,
no additional air can
get into our soda bottle.
Because no air is able
to take the place of the water,
no more water will flow out
until more water
is removed from the bowl.
This way, when your pet
drinks water from the bowl,
it will refill itself out of the soda bottle.
And if you want to start with
the bottle all the way full
so there's a maximum capacity of water,
just make sure you fill the bowl
before putting the soda bottle in.
Now, it may be obvious that this bowl
is probably bigger than it needs to be
for this size of dog.
I did want to make sure that there
is room for him to drink out of the water,
and not hit his head on the bottle.
[Music]
Hey guys.
Grant jumping back in for just a second
to remind you we're giving away
a Nintendo Switch and Mario Kart 8.
There's a link down in
the description right now
where you can click and get
your name on the list.
We're doing a random drawing
for subscriber appreciation,
and we're also sending
you the gift receipt,
because if you don't want the Nintendo,
you can take it back
and get the cash instead.